answer because you are a sir I'll give
you do you start how
life's Howie I remember first of all let
me thank Rob thank the Nexus Institute
for having me I feel a bit overwhelmed
sitting with all those wonderful people
but I also need to say that when we
spoke about that I simply told Rob that
no we are not civilized all of us and I
will start by just quoting the quote
that you sent us in your background
paper from goatee which says he
underlines that civilization protects us
from barbarism and defines it as quote a
permanent exercise in respect respect
for the divine the earth for our fellow
man and and for our own dignity unquote
and from what I've heard this morning
from what I can see I think we really
don't exercise any kind of respect
towards one another it seems that the
the population of the world has all of
us I mean east and west Muslim Christian
Jews Hindus whoever we've all sort of
internalized this theory of the fact
that there should be a clash between
civilizations and we were just acting by
it all the time and we rushed to condemn
one another and that brings me to what
was mentioned this morning the the
outcome of that is fear and hatred of
the other and all the others values of
the others culture and at the end of the
day we end up as who said this morning
humiliating one another and we end up
also not exercising what Anusol said
this morning any sense of curiosity
about one another so answer to your
question Rob I don't think we are
civilized because we don't know enough
about each other's cultures each other's
ways of life we don't bother we don't
have the curiosity to find out what are
things that can be common and what are
things that can
be differences that should also be sort
of celebrated and appreciated for what
they really are well when you ask are we
civilized it all depends on what you
mean by we certainly if you're speaking
about the West I would say that in some
ways we're civilized in some ways were
under civilized and in some ways we're
over civilized but what I want to make
are to larger observations about how to
think about your question about how to
think about this problem the first
observation is historical philosophical
the second one I think is just
philosophical the first thing I want to
say is that we have to get over our
governing assumption that there is
anything anachronistic about barbarism
we have to get past that you know for
example as my friend almost said this
morning that after September 11th he was
a 21st century in New York but then
there's the 11th century in the Middle
East I think it's very important to
recognize that Isis is as contemporary
as the iPhone and I'll say why what I
mean by that we have to get we are
always shocked by eruptions of barbarism
and if its moral shock then we must
retain the capacity for moral shock we
must never get inure to such horrors but
historical shock is a big mistake a big
analytical and philosophical mistake and
it's it's a philosophical for itself
there was nothing whatsoever shocking to
me about what happened in Paris last
night historically morally it was beyond
shock and the reason I say this is
because we need to resist first the
mythology of modernity according to
which everything changed in the modern
period and there was a total
transformation of human society and the
human person and we are now living in an
irrational age and everything that isn't
rational is a throwback or an atavism or
an archaism or an anachronism or a
survival of some primitive culture that
has nothing to do with us that is not in
any way an expression
of anything we are and similarly we have
to whereas there obviously is moral
progress in fact in the last 20 years in
my country in the United States we've
seen extraordinary moral progress in
various ways
it's a dangerous illusion to think that
that there is linear moral progress or
that moral progress is inevitable one of
the things we see regularly in the
history of moral progress that it is
always followed by spasms of moral
regress and sometimes they're incredibly
catastrophic so that as M knows fascism
and communism were the two great
allergic reactions to liberal modernity
in the West and the cost where the human
cost was incalculable so it's very so
even if we believe in moral progress
it's very important not to recognize
that it zigzags and that it's a constant
struggle it's a constant struggle and
it's a struggle that never ends and the
reason it never ends is because
civilization and barbarism I think are
best sort of has regular features of
human experience
full-stop as regular features of human
experience not as eras or entities not
as Rome or the Visigoths not as us and
them not as pure but as qualities so
that we speak of things that are
civilized and things that are barbaric
they are both human qualities and
they're both qualities of human society
and so the challenge for us becomes not
anything quite as simple as to leave
barbarism behind and embrace
civilization but to always increase our
civilized qualities and always decrease
our are barbaric qualities but we have
to so that's that's my first observation
about this this anachronism that we have
this feeling of anachronism that we have
to get over the second one is and I
wanted I was very pleased that I mean
gemayel this morning quoted walter
benjamin's famous line that there is no
document of civilization that is not
also a document to barbarism because I'd
like to put a little
you're on it partly because I'm sick of
hearing it but also I think it's I think
it's wrong in some deep way I think that
as that that view accustoms us to adieu
to accepting a kind of ironic or
dialectical relationship between
civilization and barbarism that where
there is civilization there will be
barbarism and we must always look where
there is light there will be shadow and
so on and if you will recall Benjamin's
aphorism it appears in a his sentence
appears in an aphorism on behalf of
historical materialism by which he means
a Marxist or sociological view of
culture according to which all of the
highest human expressions are
fundamentally expressions of social and
political power which in a so that truth
goodness and beauty we must stop being
naive we must recognize that that
fundamentally these are that they are
they are they are they are not illusions
but they are high high expressions of
low relations of power or to put it
differently if we accept Benjamin's view
than what we're really inflating is the
view that that a civilized society can
never be a just society and I think that
is a terrible terrible thing to to
believe I think we have to reject this
and see that that civilization and
barbarism
they don't complement each other even
though they go together they are indeed
contradictions they don't go together in
some deep way because they represent
different ideals different worldviews
different different views of society of
the human person and so on whether
religious or secular whether religious
or secular it couldn't be both versions
and so one constant you can still fight
barbarism in the name of civilization
and we don't need to be told that even
though we're fighting barbarism in the
name of civilization you know when you
fight when you use force against
barbarism that does not make you
barbaric as long as you're using for as
long as you understand that the means in
the ends and you think morally and
philosophically enjoy you know as long
as but there are it's not the case ok
etc and so the the the goal that we have
to set ourselves when we ask ourselves
are we civilized I think is whether we
can be
a society that is both increasingly
civilized and increasingly just and
increasingly just there's no question
that justice however you interpret that
has to be a feature of civilization
again we need to know what these words
mean and we could talk about that but I
would but but but that that's what I
would say
you